some very woke
black people though i mean woke in the
best sense of that term recognize that
this racial narrative
is just garbage it's trash it needs to
be rejected
it is insidious and it's harmful to
black people themselves like this
man who recently spoke at a
an illinois school board meeting he said
you think that i'm being kept down by
the white man well if i'm being kept
down by the white man then how am i so
successful
you talk about critical race theory
which is pretty much going to be
teaching kids how to hate each other
how to dislike each other that's pretty
much what it's doing
that's pretty much all i can say is
pretty much what it's going to all come
down to
you're going to deliberately teach kids
this white kid right here
got it better than you because he white
you're gonna personally tell a white kid
oh the black people are all down and
suppressed how do i have two medical
degrees if i'm sitting here oppressed
how do i get first of all you've only
got five minutes now
five minutes two medical degrees no mom
no dad in the house
worked my way through college sat there
and hustled my butt off and get through
cops you gonna tell me somebody looked
like all your white folks
kept me from doing that are you serious
not one white person ever came to me
saying well son you're never gonna be
able to get anywhere because you know
the black people but guess what
what's sickening about this whole thing
is what y'all doing right now is already
something
i do in my community right now to speak
out against stuff because black folks
are getting told by other black folks
oh you know you ain't gonna do nothing
out there in the world because then
white folks ain't gonna let you get no
you know you're not gonna be a dude here
because you know what the white man the
white man gonna keep you down well how
did i get where i am right now
if some white man kept me down how am i
now directing over folks that look just
like you guys in this room right now how
what what what kept me down what
oppressed me what oppressed me
you know there was one time i was giving
a speech at a college in
los angeles it was me and drew giving
the speech
and at one point a group of entirely
black
students come into the room with duct
tape over their mouths
and some of it said silenced or whatever
some of it was just the tape and they
obviously didn't know anything about me
or drew or the young americas foundation
which was hosting it
and they it was just that usual canard
that anybody that opposes radical
leftism is a racist and a bigot and a
terrible person
and so they had also had no idea what we
were talking about so i said hey
uh we've got these microphones up here
uh you you seem to be uh
you seem to be under the impression that
you're silenced uh so does anybody want
to come up here and talk does it do any
of you guys with the tape on your face
want to come talk
because i've got a microphone you can
make whatever point you want or ask
whatever question you want i'm happy to
talk about it
nobody would do it nobody would they
didn't have anything to say
you might say they were speechless
it's titled my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which is available for pre-order but not
for for much longer
they were silenced they had put the tape
over their own mouths i asked them that
question i said who put that tape on
your mouth
was it was it the white man was it the
system
was it the the powers that they know
of course not it was uh they themselves
who who had done it
now this guy this father who was
speaking the school board meeting
absolutely right
about this pernicious ideology critical
race theory it's just it's just awful we
talk about how it's
anti-white racism so that's bad bad for
white people
also bad for black people because it
uh creates this culture of victimhood
and grievance that
will not serve anybody well hey i'm glad
you liked that video there's a whole
show though there's a whole
episode that you could watch here on
youtube subscribe ring the bell you'll
get the notifications or
on apple podcast spotify google play
stitcher google mail
aim zanga live chat i don't know it's
all over the place
the michael knowles show subscribe leave
a five star review we'll see you there
you